[Music]
fresh fresh fresh hot off the presses
there's a new spring tour for my next
guest called the Medicine Show it kicks
off in late March we'll talk about the
dates in some of the spots a little bit
because we'll place that aside for the
moment cuz it's a big date tonight with
this the Los Angeles chargers in Mexico
City for her Kansas City Chiefs wearing
a Chiefs lid right here Grammy Award an
oscar-winning artist none other than
Melissa Etheridge good to see you rich
well welcome back to this program thank
you and we knew you wanted to come in
and talk some Chiefs like when we pick a
date for Melissa Etheridge to come in
and we just figured why not in advance
of a big Monday night perfect gotta have
this cuz guess who look who's on your
heels right here in the AFC West oh stop
don't even talk I can't believe that
we're worried about the Raiders that
just like makes me crazy they've won
three in a row they've won three in a
row and yeah but they'll lose to us you
know and yeah anyway we just have to win
tonight that's just you know I will feel
much better when we win tonight and
we're just moving on yes seven and four
heading into a bye week I mean where
where were you I assumed you were
watching the game when mahomes is me
wound up on the side of his leg oh you
know you know first we were all oh the
high ankle sprain you you know we're
about that and we because you see you
know when he's healthy he's everywhere
and you can't stop him and easy way he's
it was amazing and then you got the high
ankle sprain you see oh he's not quite
he's not running out like he used to so
he was gingerly you and then oh my god
fourth and one and he goes on and you
know when he's laying on top of the the
offensive lineman just right there and
he doesn't move and you're like oh my
god
and and then the the you know what I
think the Kansas City medical staff just
the Chiefs medical staff is just
first-rate because they they they both
the guy under him didn't move he didn't
move right they fixed it they and they
just really took care of it right in the
mall you could see like they reduced it
on the spot unbelievably amazing
I know and because very rarely do you
see an injury like that period for
anybody let alone
a quarterback sneak but I I thought of
you
I thought a Stonestreet all the Kansas
City fans that I know of our hearts what
we thought it was oh you know out for at
least six weeks if not you know oh
that's it the season then you know oh
but but and then again who knows -
because to me it was also I don't want I
don't want to say like you're you're
like me as a jet fan but looking a
little bit for the trapdoor to open up
that this is too damn good to be true
I felt this way in a long time so yeah
it was it was oh yeah there it is
there's that disappointment I remember
okay yeah right
but then again here he is back under
center and and that's really every day
much time like yeah he is he's fierce
and you know Matt Moore came out and
Matt Moore right yeah yeah I've already
forgotten him right yeah you know he
came and the the offense is so great and
then I tend to worry more about the
defense than I do about Patrick my
Holmes's legs right Melissa efforts here
on the Rich Eisen show were you watching
the game tonight in my living room
okay with my brand of course the season
bought a brand-new TV and sound system
right right it's like here the whole
like turn it all the way up the kids are
like ah it's a yeah I'll be watching it
see you at home okay so walk me through
who's who's there with you oh my wife
okay your wife your kids or no oh
they'll they come in to watch me curse
they just think it's let's go watch mama
curse it's the only time I get upset you
work blue watching the Chiefs so what
you're saying
you know a little bit a little bit I
can't help myself
come on you know it's right and of
course just the words that I've never
ever used just has come flowing from me
that's what football does it all my life
and so that's why I really only my wife
and I really watch cuz I I won't talk to
anybody else don't talk to me I'm not
available for anything right and I'm
watching so people know don't don't call
him call don't text don't talk it's it's
done between the hours of quarter one
and quarter last that's right okay are
you superstitious at all like do you
affect the outcome based on where you're
sitting in the room
that happen oh no you have no idea if if
the Chiefs asked me to sing this year I
won't because the two times that I sang
one was a Pittsburgh game early last
year yes and then the champ the champion
shares AFC championship and they lost
both so oh no I don't I think I'm bad
luck to my Chiefs when I sing so sorry
all done you're done not gonna do it
even if the Chiefs knock on the door
Chloe I would say I love you and the
reason I'm not singing is because I know
I'm saving you from myself exactly it
have you pounded the drum did you do all
that I'd like to maybe I'll pound the
drum maybe they won't lose it
Stonestreet has done that it's done that
a whole bunch of people do that I've got
a new like you know platform to pound
the drums yeah I see that you know what
I mean okay so you got that working okay
how old are your kids
oh I have two older ones 22 and 21 I'll
have two 13 year old twins okay so now
let's just say one of your 13 year old
twins comes to you one day it's his mom
I want to root for the Raiders I know
they know they've makes it so born know
that you root for the Chiefs or anyone
that's playing the Raiders right and
they tried to tease me with the Broncos
so we're gonna root on my own good luck
you know no you know they tease me but
no they know but so it's just not even a
possibility not using you you do you
want to be fed no okay so what do you
think happens tonight
oh I think I think the Chargers give us
a like they always do I think their
defense is for real huh
I think the running games for real which
worries me so Melvin Gordon has been
running the ball very well of late they
like his early season holdout he has
gotten his figurative sea legs under him
and they're beginning to run it a little
bit better than they did earlier on so I
would be I hear you unconcerned on that
front I mean I've seen our defense you
know speck no asbestos no lord thank you
speculating
it's very new horse no I'm very
Midwestern I'm no spagnolo um he's he's
good and you see them getting better but
you know we the Titans that was really
disappointing it's really hard to watch
that yes but I think that they will you
know concentrate on stopping the running
game I think they can do it I know uh
our offensive line is healthy so I'm not
worried about us offensively as much
this this time yes just you know
stopping them but then again it's Philip
Rivers and you know he'll blow it in the
last Philip will be down eight with like
four minutes left and 90 yards of the
field to go well I mean I am mandated to
say that that happened in Kansas City
last year on the final Thursday night
game of the year you know I mean he was
unbelievable
against Kansas City in your AFC
Championship season and then the but
then and then that's Philip Rivers by
the way I'm liking the bile I do like it
you know no no don't apologize again
this is what I love about fandom
football fandom your sweet person you
are known generally is just a sweet
exact nice person who likes meeting
people and just likes human life yes you
would love making people's lives better
through either your music or your words
or your essence I understanding but when
it comes to the Kansas City Chiefs
to hell with everybody exactly like you
know an all-time great lyricist how to
speak or communicate but no but I'm the
one that I will wear the I have a
Tennessee Chiefs guitar strap and when I
play Oakland or Denver or Boston I will
wear I will come out and I will start
believe me there's no microphone
especially in New England my audience
will love me love me there cheering and
uh go and I'll see you in the playoffs
and then it's all of a sudden boos it's
just ruin a show my wife says don't talk
football I can't help but to do it for
who is your chief growing up who was
your always the person that you're like
okay this is making me fall in love with
oh it was my
father okay and it was you know it was
Lenny Dawson and Hank Stram in the
1969-1970 right Chiefs I watched the
Super Bowl I saw my hometown and
everyone go crazy and it just it it of
course is last time we were in the Super
Bowl but you know you ever since then
every year you're like we could do that
again and it never goes away that never
goes away I know you know the draft is
coming in a couple of years to to Kansas
City I don't know if you're aware I'm
really excited I was so excited because
it's such a Kansas City's a beautiful
city that whole area is is they love
their Chiefs they are Chiefs they yes
they are it's a beautiful city that's
grown and has so much to offer and I
love that they've got that people can
actually see them you know I know I mean
it's the draft makes strange bedfellows
depending on where it is because when
the draft was in New York it was always
lit if you if you will in Radio City
Music Hall whenever the Giants the Jets
the Patriots or Eagles went on the clock
when we were in Dallas it was lit when
the Redskins or the Eagles went on the
clock we were in Philadelphia was lit
when the Cowboys went on the clock were
in Chicago it was lit when the Packers
were on the clock or the Bears or the
Vikings in Kansas City
I guess when the Broncos are on the
clock or the Raiders are on the clock
the Melissa Etheridge that we all know
and love is going to come out and
everybody that's in that Draft all you
know I am looking forward to that so you
announced just this morning the Medicine
Show spring tours start on the 26th of
March you're going on the road they'll
be on the east coast of the East it's
it'll be football be all done and it
won't hurt so much when I talk about it
okay yeah it'll be all done by that time
and you're also you're going to stat now
and you're going to my hometown yeah
since the st. George 305 no that's right
that's right near where the ferry is
beautiful so you're gonna play you are
you gonna take the ferry there that day
you can do that you know man it
conveniently starts well after the Super
Bowl just in case there's a mess with
your viewing oh yeah
four tickets go to Melissa Etheridge
calm and then the Melissa Etheridge
cruise calm where you're gonna be
cruising around Miami Key West
Oh Joe Rios everybody come on
fourth annual Melissa Etheridge cruise
it's going to be next October for more
tickets and information go there thanks
for coming on here always a pleasure
rich thanks for coming appreciate that
yeah good luck tonight yes good luck
I'll be okay and and you get the the
food on set you already got the it's
it's it's chips and guacamole is really
sustains me through the whole well it is
a game in Mexico I know I get a little
mad because it's the one time I could
see that Chiefs here in Austin and then
they go down to I imagine when that new
stadium yes I'm gonna be there
I'm sure you will I mean when you leave
here you've got a perfect view when you
go up you'll see it it's amazing it
really looks like a spaceship just
landed here it's unbelievable at M
Etheridge on Twitter at Melissa
underscore Etheridge on Instagram right
here in the Rich Eisen show thanks for
coming on my way you got it for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app